a few days ago this was a bustling
residential area now there are more
police and soldiers than residents as
they search debris and soil for victims
of this week's earthquake and landslides
three my wife and two children were
buried by the landslide and until now
there is no information about them
search teams have found items from his
home but there's no sign yet of his
family members
I have accepted that my family passed
away it seems impossible they could have
survived when there are so many
fatalities here but I won't ever stop
searching for them
his house was in one of the isolated
areas of Indonesia's West Java Province
rescue is initially struggled to reach
able Village in chianjor one of the
worst affected areas residents say more
than 20 houses were buried in the
landslide and dozens of their neighbors
are still missing it's where adinda
fitriani's husband was when the
earthquake hit
we were recently married and trying to
have a baby but now I must accept what
happened
Crews were able to partially clear some
roads but challenging conditions remain
including rain and aftershocks
government agencies and humanitarian
organizations are trying to get
Essentials to those in need particularly
in isolated areas
we have trucks to send Logistics and
Personnel to affected areas we also set
up clean water facilities at shelters
some are collecting Goods at
distribution centers to share with their
neighbors
all of us really need proper tent now it
is the rainy season and we need shelter
we need medicine Basic Foods like rice
eggs instant noodles milk and cooking
oil
despite the hardship there are also
moments of relief six-year-old Asuka was
found alive next to the body of his
grandmother for three days he was
trapped under a collapsed wall the
unexpected Story of Survival is a
welcome reprieve for a community going
through this together Jessica Washington
Al Jazeera tianjour Indonesia